nous sommes au coeur du quartier de
shahjoy à qui a été l'un des quartiers
de gaza les plus affectées surtout
depuis le lancement de l'offensive
terrestre des forces armées israéliennes
dans quelques jours seulement 170
personnes sont mortes ici dans ce
quartier maintenant aujourd'hui les
choses semblent plus calme mais on
entend toujours au dessus de nous le
survol des drones qui est constant au
loin on entend aussi des coups de feu
des tirs d'artillerie également un peu
plus tôt on a croisé une équipe de la
défense civile du gouvernement du hamas
qui venait récupérer des corps
profitaient de l'accalmie ils ont
demandé un cessez le feu temporaire pour
venir récupérer ces corps on leur a
refusé l'autorisation malgré tout ils
sont venus ils nous ont raconté que huit
membres d'une même famille étaient morts
dans un des bombardements et que deux
des cadavres avaient été laissées
derrière au moment où on arrivait il
retrouvait justement le deuxième de ses
cadres il s'agit de deux frères jumeaux
de 18 ans les gens air un peu dans les
rues on en a vu plusieurs qui quittait
toujours avec des petits baluchon on a
croisé un couple de personnes âgées qui
revenait comme les choses s'étaient
légèrement calmée se demandant si
c'était sécuritaire de s'avancer plus
loin pour voir ce qui était advenu de
leurs maisons de leurs voisins
maintenant les combats semblent se
déplacer dans le sud de la bande de gaza
la nuit a été très très dur pour la
population de rang dionis les dizaines
de personnes déjà ont trouvé la mort
dans l'oeuf en civ
on ne peut qu'imaginer que des simples
comme on en a vu un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui vont se répéter pendant
quelques jours dans ce secteur
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada shan
zhai à gaza